[Music]
let's talk about red to work you worked
with mr. Bruce Willis this guy is
incredible
yeah action star family very manly why
do you say that as if I don't know what
very manly or no no you why did you act
what I mean I guess you are the paradigm
of masculinity but you know first verse
is very manly and one time we were
shooting a scene actually out of hell
uh-huh very cute and she's making this
movie yeah and there was a B M scared of
bugs kind of and there was a B and it
was all and he took his whip cheese prop
gun out of his pocket blew it away it
was a this far away from my face blew
the B away shot it it's a prop gun that
had like a real church yes yes but a
blank is enough to take out a B he shot
that knew your face shot it dead because
he's Bruce Willis so he can shoot a B
and it's not gonna like take out part of
my nose or something because he's in the
back how does he know he went to real
gun with a live charge out there's a be
near your nose and he shot at the B it
it blew the B away and you're okay
you're not crazily faced about yes there
was so sexy I mean and then he just kind
of put it back his pocket was back to
being like first Willis it was really it
was quite hot yeah well now we guys know
what you ladies like
but I asked him like a month later cuz I
said remember that time when we were on
the hill because it was just a real that
I didn't even really acknowledge it much
at the time and he said you know there
was a bee and you yeah I shot the B for
you babe I'm just glad you're alive
those are dangerous you're right he is
more of a man than me oh I wouldn't
shoot a live round into your face